Wolfie, wolfie, wolfie, wolfie! [screams]
Candle wax? Yeah, that's done.
But he wouldn't be screaming
his head off like that.
It doesn't hurt that bad.
Hi, my name is Mistress Damiana Chi.
I have been a professional dominatrix
in Los Angeles for over two decades.
I have a Ph.D. in clinical psychology,
and I am a certified sexologist.
Today, we're going to be
looking at dominatrix scenes
in movies and TV and
judge how real they are.
Let me see you oink, piggy.
[men oinking and squealing]
[Kat laughing]
So ... [laughs]. All these guys
that are acting like clowns,
so not authentic.
A true submissive would go
into something called subspace,
which is a switch in the mindset
where they're feeling submissive.
And I can see it easily in subs.
They've got an energetic shift
or a certain look in their eye.
In that scene, the submissives were
obviously not feeling submissive.
They were making fun of themselves.
It's kind of been done
over and over and over
to use BDSM for shock
value, comedic value.
It's getting old, in my opinion.
My dream in life is to bankrupt you.
She says, "My fantasy is to
bankrupt you." It's real.
It is not what I believe true BDSM is.
Financial domination has kind of exploded,
unfortunately, on the internet.
Most financial domination
that is done out there is unethical
because they are done by girls like this
who have zero training in domination.
BDSM is not about taking
advantage of people.
It's about true connection.
It's about trust.
It's about mutual respect.
Looking at someone's social-media account
is not a good way to vet someone.
I have a vetting process
where I ask for references
from the client's previous doms.
But if he doesn't have any references,
I ask for a fee for a phone interview.
Going back and forth on DMs like this,
you're just giving them free time.
As a dom, if you feel in any way
pushed into doing something
for the money, don't do it.
It happens a lot to younger doms
and younger doms who are untrained.
This character is in high school,
and I don't admit anyone
into my dominatrix academy
that's under 21.
I would rate this an 8 out of 10.
It's true to what's happening
right now in society.
It's not true to the art form of BDSM.
Did you kidnap this man
and steal his house?
What do you take me for? He invited us.
Everything so far, really authentic.
The fantasy is that the
submissive is suffering
in his own house while the ladies are just
having a great time at his expense.
What he's wearing, too,
he's wearing headphones and a blindfold.
He's got, like, a latex bodysuit on.
And the cage as well.
He can't stretch out. It's a short cage.
That's pretty authentic as well.
How does he go to the
bathroom in this thing?
We deprive him of food all weekend long,
so no worries about No. 2.
Otherwise, he just goes when he has to.
Oh, girl.
[laughs] Still authentic.
The way that the dom is acting is great.
She's really aloof.
If you want to be a super-cruel dom,
you can do it this way,
where she's being like,
"Oh, he can just go when he wants to."
There's other ways that I've done.
I've had my sub wear a diaper.
I've done it where I'll
administer a catheter,
and that is my favorite way
because I'm controlling everything.
Feeling dehydrated, Joe? Light-headed?
Joe: No, I'm feeling amazing.
[laughs]
This is where the
authenticity starts falling.
A dom would say, "You're probably getting
a little dehydrated by
now, but guess what?
I will hydrate you when I
feel like hydrating you."
In the back of her mind, she has a plan.
She's keeping him safe,
but she's not spelling it out for him,
and so now the scene is turned to, like,
top-bottom dynamic rather
than a dom-sub dynamic.
She's acting like what
we call a service top.
There's not that control thing happening.
And cover me up again?
Elektra: How long before
we should come back?
Tomorrow?
There he is giving orders to the dom.
"Cover me up again."
"Check on me tomorrow."
He's not being a submissive.
That's not very fun.
The fun part about being a submissive is
you don't know when stuff
is going to happen to you.
With this scene, he's not real
restricted in his movement.
I wouldn't leave someone like that,
not longer than, like, two, three hours.
If I leave, I'll have
somebody that's assisting me
to watch over them.
Sometimes I'll have a camera.
I rate this a 7 out of 10.
They lost some points there at the end.
Jordan: Aah! Jesus Christ!
Venice: You like that?
Jordan: Ow, owie!
Love her outfit. She's beautiful,
and she looks very dom-like.
I like it! I like it! Ow!
[laughs]
They obviously wanted to make
a comedic scene here out of it.
Here he is, lying there,
and his legs are flailing
and he's just moving all over the place.
A sub that flails like that
should've been put in bondage.
Jordan: Wolfie, wolfie, wolfie, wolfie!
[screams]
Shut up!
Candle wax? Yeah, that's done.
She's doing it on his back,
which, that's a safe
place to do candle wax,
but he wouldn't be screaming
his head off like that.
He might be screaming
if she's using a candle
that isn't safe to play in BDSM scenes.
I don't have subs that
scream their heads off
because I use low-burning wax.
It doesn't hurt that bad.
Yeah, it's my safe word,
baby. It's my safe word.
I don't give a f--- about your safe word.
The, "I don't give a f---
about your safe word,"
it is unsafe for a dom
to say that and do that
and ignore the sub's
calling out his safe word.
What if that candle is one
of those high-burning candles
that is scorching his
skin and it might actually
be burning him way more
than she thinks it is?
In that case, the sub has to just get up
and walk out the door as best as he can.
I would rate this a 3 out of 10.
Her saying, "I don't give a
f--- about your safe word,"
that kind of blew it there.
Christian: The following are the terms
of a binding contract
between the Dominant and the Submissive.
Authentic. Mm-hmm. This
sort of contract is done
between partners in a
lifestyle DS relationship,
versus a professional
relationship, somebody like me.
Christian: The Safeword
"Yellow" will be used
to bring to the attention of the dominant
that the submissive is close to her limit.
This is very well written, very thorough.
Those are the most common safe words
used in the BDSM scene in general.
Sometimes the safe words are not verbal.
Let's say I have someone in bondage
and he's gagged and he can't speak.
Then I'll give him a little hand signal.
I'll say, like,
[slaps leg] pound the table three times.
Christian: The Submissive
will eat regularly
to maintain her health and well-being.
The Submissive will not
drink to excess, smoke ...
I liked how he put things in
there about her self-care.
When the dom is controlling
every aspect of her life,
she feels very, very cared for.
It's very much like that
dynamic of the parent-child.
All of the parts where
he's explaining to her
what she's allowed to eat,
it's seen as a positive.
It's not seen as a negative at all.
I would rate this a 10 out of 10.
All those implements, very authentic.
In fact, one of the floggers
that was hanging there
looks just like the one that I have here.
Wendy: Look at all the
trouble you've caused.
Leave with me or administer
the required corrections.
Oh, love it.
First of all, all the dungeon
equipment that I've seen here,
it's made for a real BDSM dungeon.
The double doms, that happens a lot.
They're having a dialogue,
mistress and mistress,
talking about him like he's just
a third party who's not even there.
Have you missed this?
Then why aren't you showing
the proper appreciation?
I should put you in this f---ing cage.
This is what I've been waiting for,
to see something like this.
You know how you feel the drama?
There's a lot of drama
in a real BDSM scene.
It's serious. It could feel scary.
And explored other fantasies then.
Wendy: What fantasies exactly?
You being with other men.
He's asking her if she fantasizes
about being with other men.
That is very real.
The fantasy of being
cuckolded is very common.
The cuckolding fantasy is
where the dominant mistress
has sexual relations with another person,
and it's a turn-on, because
it hurts his feelings.
You want to be punished? [chains rattling]
Yes. It's the most excruciating
thing that I can think of.
We're somewhere private.
Chuck: A hotel?
Wendy: A hotel.
[Wendy flogs Chuck]
Oh, God. Ooh!
I have chills running
up the back of my head.
He said, "That's the
most excruciating thing
that I can think of."
So to him that's more painful
than any physical pain
that she could administer.
Finally, he's being serious.
He's going through all the emotions
that a submissive would.
And then she said something
like, "Is it in a hotel?"
You know, so she's
fantasizing with him now,
so she's making him visualize it.
Very, very real. It's very hot, very good.
Easy 10 out of 10.
Everything about it was excellent.
I noticed this immediately.
The flogging technique is not right.
The flogger just wrapped
around his shoulder.
Wrapping is bad technique
because you can't control
how hard you're hitting.
So what she should do is
stand a little bit back
so that it doesn't wrap
over his shoulder like that.
So, at the beginning,
it showed him smile a little bit, right?
That's so fake.
He might get into a
euphoric state later on,
but not in the first
minute. He'd be wincing.
That part is real.
She was doing aftercare.
What aftercare is,
when the dom cares for
the submissive physically,
emotionally, because you're coming down
from a really, really heavy scene.
So, tending to his wounds
is a good part of aftercare
if the submissive needs it,
and also she was having
conversation with him.
During aftercare, what I do with my subs
is I bond with them,
sometimes on topics outside of the scene.
I thought it was really, really good
that they included the
aftercare in this show,
because that part's not seen a lot.
So I'm going to rate this a 4 out of 10.
[sub grunting]
Oh, oh!
Such a great start!
What she's doing is called trampling.
She's not using her full
weight of her heels,
which, that's dangerous,
you shouldn't do that,
but she's doing it right.
Belle: Stop moving
Sub: Sorry, mistress.
I shall have to punish you.
The, "Stop moving, I
shall have to punish you."
Typical dominatrix line.
Reading the magazine too is great,
because that's kind of like, you know,
I'm just doing my normal thing
while you're down there suffering.
And he's calling her mistress.
So finally we see that.
Please stop.
OK, get up if you want.
No.
No! Don't ruin it!
That's not what a mistress would say.
When he said stop, in the scene,
that was a part of him wanting
to be helpless and resistant,
and he wanted to prompt her
to role-play back to him.
He was trying to say, "No,
I don't want to get up."
So that kind of showed her naivete.
It fits the storyline of the episode,
her being a new mistress.
How do you know if you're doing it right?
In my job, if you make him
out and come, that's success.
With this, I can't even
tell if he's enjoying it.
There are other ways to figure out
if a sub is enjoying things or not.
If it's a stone-cold look on his face,
he's stopped breathing,
to me, these are red lights.
I would time out and
say, "OK. What's wrong?"
Just a minute.
You disgust me!
I've run out ideas, and
I've still got ages to go.
[laughs]
That's natural.
New dom is going to run out
of ideas, and she's going to,
maybe not ask in the middle of a session,
advice from someone.
But the look on her face
and, "You disgust me," great.
It's showing that she's still
got a handle on her mistress role.
And then do the kitchen!
The guy licking the toilet,
realistic, actually.
I've done that.
It's not super common.
If I ever made someone do that,
I would make sure that the
toilet is not, like, filthy.
I would rate this a 9 out of 10.
It was very realistic.
Now help me with this tarp.
You're peeing on Fred.
Tiff, I get pee shy.
Yeah, assistants happen,
when the dom doesn't want
to do a particular thing.
Sometimes the client will want someone
that's more vanilla than
me, that isn't a dominatrix,
and maybe another part of a special kink
is having this boy do it
instead of the dominatrix.
I wouldn't call someone
who acted like this person,
who was hesitant about it.
It would ruin the scene.
I told my friends how funny you were.
You tell people about us?
Damiana: OK, no.
Clients don't tell their friends.
This is a secret, private thing.
Sometimes if they're in the kink community
then they'll tell those
friends in the community.
No.
I don't wear raincoats
when I pee on someone.
That must be part of
the set designer's idea
because they have a plastic tarp under him
and they want it to match.
That's all for looks, for TV.
Where do you want it, Freddy?
OK, stop. The, "Where do you want it?"
They're acting like he's
getting his hair done.
It's not like that. How a BDSM scene works
is that you have the pre-scene talk,
where you might have negotiations,
and then once you get into the scene,
you don't really ask those
types of questions anymore.
I would rate this a 1 out of a 10.
I was thinking, like, maybe we could
do something a little different today.
Everything here, it looks very realistic,
like it's actually in
somebody's private dungeon.
Like, a room in their house
or something like that.
Sarah: I play your part. You play my part.
Sure. We'll have to do a quick contract.
What's your safe word?
Pony: Red.
That can happen. This feels
like a top-bottom scene to me.
There's not a lot of formality to it.
Like, "OK, let's not do
that. Let's do this."
In the middle of it, she wanted to switch,
so they threw in a bunch
of BDSM terminology there.
"We should do a quick contract."
"My safe word is red."
It seems like a real
lifestyle scene to me.
Sarah: You know what I should do?
I should beat the s--- out of
you. That's what I should do.
I should f---ing cut
off your f---ing head!
Red!
Yeah, super intense.
She's taking out something
else on this person.
You should never bring anger into a scene,
either about the sub or about anything.
When there's real anger involved,
you should not be doing any BDSM at all.
So, that was really
intense for me to watch,
and I'm glad she called red,
and hopefully she did stop,
because this kind of thing happens.
I would rate this a 10 out of 10,
because this seemed like
a very real lifestyle
scene to me gone wrong.
My favorite TV show featuring
a dominatrix is "Billions,"
inspired by the clip that I saw here,
because it was the most
realistic domination that I had seen.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video,
why not click the video above?